salt crusted sea bream served with
braised leeks and hazelnuts
first job is that salt crust
this dish looks intimidating but it is
actually very straightforward and very
easy make sure the guts are out and the
fish is clean the most important thing
is always leaving the skin and the
scales on that skin protects the actual
flesh from becoming salty give
the fish a really nice seasoning
inside even though we're putting a salt
crust on the outside it's still very
important to season the middle fennel
seeds
goes brilliantly well with fish and then
slice the lemon nice
large thick slices the zest
and the lemon bakes inside the fish
fold over the fish and just squeeze
the juice now for the salt
about 150 mil to 200 ml of water
what you're trying to do now is just
bring the salt
together
and you want to sort of end up with a
bowl of salt that looks almost like snow
you'll need about two kilos of salt for
this and it doesn't need to be the fancy
stuff even though you're using a lot of
it it won't make the fish salty instead
the crust forms a kiln that retains
moisture
now basically
a nice bed of salt underneath
flatten it down
lay the fish on top of the salt
get your salt
and just start packing you can salt
crust almost any fish from sea bass to
salmon or flat fish like seoul but it's
not great with oily fish
now it looks like a ridiculous amount of
salt but it's really important to cover
all the fish
because you want that nice shell and the
minute salt hits the oven it sort of
tightens up and forms this
large
crust that goes in at 180 degrees for 25
to 30 minutes
whilst the fish cooks is onto my
beautiful braised leeks
splash of olive oil
leek is a very sort of firm robust
vegetable so it can take a really nice
sear the most exciting thing about these
leagues are they go gooseweek with the
sea breeze but braised leeks colored
properly with a lot of flavor on there
tastes absolutely delicious
take a couple of cloves of garlic and
just crush them in with the leeks some
fresh thyme
get some butter in there
raising them in butter and white wine
gives them the most amazing flavor
braising is a chefy term for searing at
a high temperature then cooking with a
bit of liquid
bring that up to the boil
and then
the rest of your butter
now
as the white wine reduces down the
flavor of the leeks intensifying they
glaze
turn it down
just leave that little gap there if we
totally
covered it then you're gonna get all
that condensation from beneath the lid
and it'll just make the leeks watery
the leeks will take about 12 minutes to
cook so now for the garnish
roasted hazelnuts they'll be roasted in
the oven very brittle very firm so get
them inside pestle and water a bit of
seasoning and just crush your nuts
don't over pound them i just want this
nice sort of rustic chopped toasted
hazelnuts now
get your knife you want that going
through with ease and turn off the gas
right absolutely adore them
like stunning little parcels
soft and slightly creamy
now baste the leeks with the remaining
butter
spread your flat leaf parsley over
generously
and then just sprinkle
the toasted hazelnuts
the combination of that earthiness from
the leeks the roasted flavour from the
hazelnuts that
is a stunning way of eating leeks
and now for the fish
and look
now just gently tap
the top
and it starts
falling away
you can just see
that beautiful
shine carefully lift off
your salt
now
peel that skin
look how juicy and succulent that sea
beam is
stays incredibly moist
the other great thing about cooking
whole fish like this it makes it so easy
to fill it
take your spoon
run that down
through the top
and the fish will just slide off
there
now
just
push back that lovely it and look
that
is cooked beautifully
that's what keeps them coming back for
more
and more and more when you have friends
over you want to keep lunch relaxed laid
back but impressive
and a salt crust bring with beautiful
braised leeks is just that
all over southeast asia you find people
cooking and eating the huge bowls of
delicious noodle soups it's a very
simple dish but the variations you get
are extraordinary different meats
different fish and even different
dumplings but what i love most about
noodle soup is the fact is the complete
meal carbs protein and vegetables in one
big bowl of happiness for my ultimate
southeast asian lunch i'm showing you
one of my favorites
spicy clam and noodle soup followed by
sweet morish banana and coconut fritters
for dessert
first up my dessert banana fritters
take your bananas
and to get them really nice and soft
just rub
the banana sip together flour and baking
powder
sugar into the flour
then add coconut for texture and a pinch
of salt
sounds strange in the dessert but it
works brilliantly especially with the
fritters it makes the batter nice and
crisp
start
crushing and use the back
of the fork and just push it against the
side of the bowl
and then
once you've mixed that through
i'm gonna make that mix now slightly
fragrant with some lime zest
now
the lime
just really elevates the sort of
richness and the denseness of the banana
cover with clim film so it doesn't get a
skin on top sit that in the fridge for
15 minutes
as the banana fritter mixture rests i'm
getting on with my broth for the noodle
and clam soup
fish stock is the base
bring that up to the boil now to take
that broth to another level
in with chopped shallots
fresh ginger add a whole chili seeds and
all i actually quite like it
spicy
just
chop once and into the broth
bring up to the ball and let it simmer
galangal
it's sort of
almost like a softer version of ginger
slightly milder
you can use galangal paste but i prefer
the fresh stuff
the stems
for the coriander we'll finish the broth
with the
heads and that's what endeared me to the
southeast asian style of cooking
across my travels there was there's no
waste in
lime leaves
for me
one of my favorites incredibly pungent
strong full of flavor very acidic but
gives a really nice aroma to the broth
just tear them
in
now the lemongrass
so the secret here
that's where all the flavor is right at
the very end so you take the back of the
knife and you just bash the lemongrass
it's all that flavor is gonna run out in
seconds that's the base
of the broth done the longer you leave
it the more intense it gets whilst the
broth infuses soak your rice noodles in
boiling water for 10 minutes just enough
time to fry your fritters the batter now
is ready
use a metal spoon to drop the batter to
the bottom of the pan
i mean they hit that oil they puff up
that's why it's important to put your
spoon into the oil so the mixture runs
off
it creates this lovely little fritter
and then gently
fry get a slotted spoon and nice and
carefully turn them over
smell
of that lime is extraordinary
fry for two to three minutes
as they start floating
it signifies the fact that they're
cooked
off with a gas
and just let them drained
are those beauties
lovely
sprinkling when they're hot with a sugar
actually sticks to them
they're done ready to go
the last job before serving the clams
never be scared of cooking shellfish the
most important rule is if they are
slightly opened
a millimeter discard it make sure
muscles clams are always tight cook the
clams for just three to five minutes or
until they're all open
bring that up to the boil and this is
where we finish the broth
touch of
fish sauce a little sprinkle of sugar
drain your noodles
into the bowl
for added texture
some delicious bean sprouts
get your lime
fresh squeeze and lime juice in
beautiful literally as the stock comes
up to the boil the clams open
automatically
so they cook beautifully
the flavor from inside the clam has
enhanced the broth
smell is incredible
the clams cooked finish with fresh
coriander and serve
there you have
perfect lunch
a delicious spicy clam noodle
with an amazing banana fritter
my spicy clam noodle soup and banana and
coconut fritters made in minutes and
proof you only need to travel as far as
your kitchen to get the taste of
southeast asia
[Music]
succulent zingy prawn tostadas and for
dessert salty caramel popcorn so good
you'll want to eat it by the handful
you can't beat
properly home-cooked popcorn
start off with just a touch
of oil in there as it lightly starts to
smoke
corn in
so now get your lid never leave it far
away from you
sounds like it's raining it's not
so it's popcorn canals trying to pop out
boom
delicious
just a little shake of the pan
get it going
and then lift that lid
at your apparel
we
see
it's a very exciting pan in there
and when all that little pita pattern
stops you know your popcorn is cooked
nice
you could eat it fresh from the pan but
i've got another plan i'm gonna make a
salted caramel popcorn start off with
your sugar into the hot pan
never stir a caramel otherwise it
crystallizes it's a salted caramel so a
nice pinch
of salt in there as well
now once you've got it to a really nice
dark caramel flavor stir in your butter
very carefully caramel is very very hot
half a teaspoon of bicarbonate of soda
kickstarts the reaction that gives the
caramel a honeycomb flavor
mix that in
you'll see it
reacting
almost like a large crunchy
in the bottom of your bowl
now the gas is off and that caramel has
a nice dark rich
flavor
now pour in the popcorn to coat it with
that incredible caramel give that a good
mix
it's that easy and it's gonna taste
amazing
lay that nice and flat
once that cools down it becomes nice and
brittle we've got that nice salted
caramel flavor which just takes popcorn
to complete dim level whilst the popcorn
cools down it's onto my prawn tostada
wonderful prawns gonna marinade them
first with a little bit of garlic
nice and fine
[Music]
and don't worry if you can't slice
thinly just
get a little grater and grate the garlic
nice and fine as well nice pinch of
chili flakes over your prawn garlic in
salt
pepper
and olive oil give that a really nice
little mix
whilst the prawns marinade i'm gonna
knock up a salad this is a really nice
sort of light fragrant salad
radishes topped and tailed and then into
quarters
cherry tomatoes halved
spring onions sliced
and seasoned
and then just to liven things up a
little bit of chili in there
and slice them on an angle
now the avocado cut in half
give that a little twist
so you just go down
and down and down carefully with your
knife
turn it around
go down and down and down and then
you take your spoon and you've got your
diced avocado
coming out already
now baby gem lettuce half then shred
freshly squeezed lime juice and a little
drizzle
of olive oil tostada is a classic
mexican style open tortilla so
that lime complements it beautifully
lastly roughly chop coriander and give
it a mix that is the perfect base
for our tostada the salad's ready now
for the prawns and don't be afraid of
getting the pan nice and hot
teaspoon
of olive oil in
anything less than that sizzle when you
put that first prawn in there don't put
them in
keep them nice and flat
make sure you've got all that marinade
in there as well watch them change color
rapidly i'd rather cook them
quicker in a hotter pan
and slower in a colder pan the
difference in taste is night and day
the prawns will take just two minutes to
cook through
lime juice just over the top nice
toss them over the lime
these are
corn
tortilla quite robust
and there's a kind of base that doesn't
disintegrate hot pan in
it's a dry pan
so
that corn tortilla goes nice and crispy
on the outside
[Music]
look
crispy shell
to build them generous with the salad
that base will stay nice and crisp
next
with your prawns i like to keep the
tails
in to the center
and lay the round
part of the prawn
on the outside
and there we have
a delicious yeah very humble prawn
tostada followed by my superb salty
caramel popcorn
beautiful
[Music]
prawn tostadas and salty caramel popcorn
vibrant irresistible smelling dishes
you'll want to dive into
you